Well, sine is opposite just 5 meters over hypotenuse which is 13.
Notice I didn't actually include the m when I was writing because
it's a ratio and the unit will cancel out.
The last ratio we have is the cosine abbreviated cos.
This is equal to the adjacent side over the hypotenuse.
The cosine of 22.6 degrees is 12 over 13, so here you have your trigonometric ratios.
A common way to remember these three ratios is with the following mnemonic--
SOH CAH TOA--this means that the sine is equal to the opposite of the hypotenuse,
cosine adjacent over hypotenuse, and the tangent is opposite over adjacent.
If this helps you remember these three functions, that's great.